[Music]
peter is with us in chicago hi peter how
are you
i'm getting good how about yourself
better than i deserve what's up
so
a little bit of background for the last
three years since the pandemic
i have been paying for my parents
mortgage and home equity
my
question is
unfortunately i think i missed the
opportunity for low rates but my
question is
i still have three options i can either
continue paying the
principal and interest which i'm
currently doing they are covering the
property taxes that's option number one
continue what i'm currently doing paint
three thousand dollars a month with that
um why are you paying your parents
mortgage
well
because they currently can't afford it
they want to stay in their house i'm an
only child and i would do and will do
anything i can to
pay them back for being fantastic
parents and giving me an amazing job i
help them avoid reality why can't they
pay their mortgage
uh
at the start of the pandemic my
dad had to
retire
and
my
team continuing industry
that had some ageism and he just aged
he was kind of forced to age out a
little bit how old is he
uh he is 66.
so what did he do for a living
he is a substitute teacher
right now before he was um in another
industry he was making both of my
parents are in their 70s
as as professors
as
as teachers
and that's definitely an option because
you could take can you afford 3 000 i
mean this is different do you make 25
grand a month and this is no big deal
um
i should probably know a month off top
ahead but for a year it's 110.
it's like how old are you
yeah 29
and you're single i'll take it
yeah okay
all right
uh you live with them
i didn't move back that depends during
the pandemic which is why i was happy to
help them out um
to take a step back dave this was
not um supposed to be a long-term
solution it was supposed to be temporary
yeah
of getting a gaming job he was really
good in his industry he had experience
and they have no money
um
their combined primary around
45 a year yeah and what's the house
worth
it's uh seven seven times yeah and what
do they owe on it
uh they owe uh 283.
yeah they need to sell it and buy a
house for 500 000 is paid for
yeah uh
that's a that's a non-starter um no it
is a star
it's a complete starter total starter
the non-starter is this dysfunctional
crap that you're weaving that is your
life that's the non-starter
the non-starter is a 29 year old is
taking care of these fully capable
adults who need to get off their butts
and take care of themselves
it is not an act of love there is so
much weirdness going on behind the
scenes in this conversation i can't
breathe especially some sort of return
on investment as though
they were great parents and so they're
entitled to x percent of your
of your income because they don't want
to work yeah or they didn't save up or
they made some life choices i'm all
about helping your parents out man let's
pretend that you had a job that was
making twenty thousand dollars a year
and you were in an apartment
uh and they were in this pickle you know
what they would do
they would sell their house and buy a
500 000 house and get a job to be able
to live there that's what they would do
so it's not a non-starter uh you are
trying to make their fantasy world exist
and it's not sustainable and you are
participating in the fantasy as though
the fantasy that you can prop them up
and keep this thing going forever
this is has such a short runway and it's
gonna then it's gonna hit the wall and
it's gonna disintegrate like nascar and
the engine's gonna fly up in the stands
i mean this is this is you got about two
to three years on this before the all
the emotions in this mess melt down and
the and the finances unravel
so this is not a refinance question this
is a uh peter you've made some you guys
have made a mistake of trying to you
were nice to come in and and
with an umbrella when it was raining
but an umbrella is not a structure
that's sustainable
in a in a monsoon and you're that so
these folks need to make some decisions
about their income and their housing
like grown-ups and then you need to go
on and love them
be kind to them and you can assist them
occasionally but this idea that you took
them to raise is just dysfunctional dude
that's the non-starter yeah
it's it's just all in your story and
it's weird
and i'm not picking on you i'm not
shaming you i just want you to hear it
loud and clear because you aren't it
you're nowhere near hearing it that's
why i'm smacking you so hard because i
really want to shake you a little bit
and get your attention because
this is not good
mental health it's not good relational
health but more importantly you're
you're intentionally sacrificing your
future to not to keep somebody alive but
to prop up a fantasy
there's two and there's a difference
there right
um
they're sitting on half a million
dollars
yeah anyway we could talk all day yeah
it's called that's the thing open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so here's the thing
john let's talk about this minute
because it comes up with boundaries
issues and this is a kind of a
boundaries question in a sense
all the time um
this we call we call uh
the 30s and 40s he's a little young for
it but we call them the sandwich
generation because they've got their
kids to raise them put through college
and many times their parents
have got issues and they're sandwiched
between both of the financial needs
pulling at them
so you have to have
real clear boundaries and love and many
of uh many of my brothers and sisters in
christ
um
twist
and make toxic
the scripture that says to honor your
father and mother
and that means that we have to do
whatever no it doesn't
if your mom is doing cocaine you are not
honoring her by giving her money right
it's not honor
that's participation in dysfunction
that is not honoring that is not an act
of love
that is not an act of honor
that is a dysfunction